à surréaliste selon ses mots anglais la
merkel pour mais de vous reconstruire là
généralement
venus constater les dommages causés par
les inondations qui ont frappé l'ouest
de l'europe l'allemagne paie le plus
lourd tribut avec au moins 157 morts
angela merkel appelle à se presser
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france le projet de
loi sur les nouvelles mesures sanitaires
en france entame cette semaine son
parcours parlementaire il sera présenté
demain en conseil des ministres dès le
lendemain mardi le texte sera examiné à
l'assemblée avant le sénat jeudi au
coeur de la loi l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants et l'extension du
passé ni terres à de nombreux lieux
publics
dernière mesure dont les modalités de
contrôle inquiète les professionnels
concernés dont les colonnes du journal
du dimanche ce matin le ministre de
l'économie s'est montré rassurant
le pass sanitaire ne devrait pas
affecter le chiffre d'affaires des
secteurs concernés que nous continuons
par ailleurs à soutenir tout au long de
l'été grâce au fonds de solidarité
présenter un qr code ça ne prend que
quelques secondes et ça préserve du
risque de contamination et bruno le
maire qui a précisé que seuls les grands
centres commerciaux seront concernées
par l'obligation d'un contrôle sanitaire
à partir de début août
réaction de gontran turing délégué
général du conseil national des centres
commerciaux
la mesure contre laquelle nous sommes
c'est l'application du pass sanitaires
pour effectivement entrer dans les
centres commerciaux
on pense que c'est une mesure qui est un
affront inacceptable et inapplicable
il n'accepte pas parce qu'elle est
discriminante pourquoi les centres
commerciaux pourquoi pas dans ce cas-là
l'ensemble des commerces
pourquoi les grands centres commerciaux
est d'ailleurs contradictoire puisque ce
sont en général les gros centres
commerciaux qui sont les mieux équipés
pour pratiquer les autocars sanitaires
qui ont déjà été mises en place et qui
ont fait leurs preuves voilà le
caractère inacceptable de cette mesure
où la firme oh et puis ensuite quelques
hôtels et n'entendent inapplicable donc
on bruno le maire qui pour quelques
secondes
nous avons fait des tests in-situ pour
voir effectivement première de temps
prenait la vérification dax perd 4 ça
prend 1 minimath 30 secondes
par ailleurs il faudrait recruter
environ 5000 nouveaux avant sécuritaire
aux quinze jours pour assurer le
contrôle à l'entrée des centres
sachant par ailleurs qu'il faudrait
filtrer entre les les consommateurs qui
viendrait pour la galerie marchande et
les consommateurs qui viendrait pour
l'hypermarché ou pour ou par la
pharmacie donc c'est tout à fait
inapplicable sur le terrain l extension
du pas salutaire qui a fait descendre
dans la rue hier
près de 114 mille un protestataire un
peu partout en france à paris chiffres
étaient environ 18000 selon la
préfecture
un appel à manifester à l'initiative de
gilet jaune et de quelques personnalités
politiques
retour sur ce samedi de mobilisation
avec nos combats les slogans fusent
[Applaudissements]
la colère est prégnante hier selon le
ministère de l'intérieur près de 114
mille manifestants ont dénoncé
l'extension du pas salutaire en france
comme ici à paris
parmi les organisateurs du rassemblement
nicolas dupont aignan et florian
philippot ne mâchent pas leurs mots face
à la décision des manuels macro on est
unis on est rassembler
des forces qui sont quand même de tuvalu
horizons de tous horizons et ça c'est
formidable aussi et je crois que les
gens disent stop voit la liberté je dois
pas cette discrimination
stop à cet apartheid stop à cette
tyrannie macro nist il faut arrêter le
délire communiste
c'est le début d'un engrenage vers une
dictature c'est un coup d'état
sanitaires c'est l'instrumentalisation
de la peur de la maladie
pour asseoir un pouvoir de plus en plus
illégitime preuve de la mobilisation
dans les pyrénées orientales département
récemment touchée par une forte reprise
épidémique est peint de nouvelles
mesures de restriction
la mobilisation est forte au moins 1500
personnes ont sillonné perpignan pour
dire non au pass annie terre de son côté
le premier ministre jean castex
en visite dans les pyrénées atlantiques
a réaffirmé leur volonté gouvernementale
ce variant delta il est là il ne faut
pas se cacher la vérité il progresse
il est très contagieux il est plus
contagieux que les variants précédent
nous devons nous aussi nous adapter et
faire face en faisant en sorte que en
face peser le moins possible de
contraintes sur l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et pour ça je le répète et
je le répèterai elle a simplement il n'y
a qu'une solution en tout cas une
solution prioritaire c'est la
vaccination une stratégie qui convainc
une majorité de français selon deux
raisons sondage publié en début de
semaine
mais pour les pourfendeurs du pas de
sanitaires la parole gouvernementale ne
passe plus
de ce pas sanitaire mais j'en passe que
du mal que du moins
que du monde je veux pouvoir circuler
marché aller faire mes courses
vivre c'est une loi qui est totalement
abusive c'est une loi qui divisent les
français c'est une loi qui est
absolument insupportable qui est
disproportionné par rapport à la
situation
on va rappeler bien évidemment qu'en
face c'est pas écolo il s'agit du
coronavirus les vaccins sont pas au
point donc vacciner au pas vaccinés ça
change pas grand chose
des rassemblements qui se sont
globalement déroulées dans le calme même
si quelques échauffourées avec les
forces de l'ordre
au lieu à dijon ou encore à lyon de
nouvelles mobilisations contre
l'extension du pass à lithaire
pourraient être organisées la semaine
prochaine à cinq jours de l'ouverture
des jo de tokyo les organisateurs
redoutant foyers de contamination au
sein du village olympique quatre cas
positifs au coville ci ont été recensés
tous appartiennent à la délégation sud
africaine
un premier foyer épidémique qui met à
l'épreuve les mesures sanitaires préparé
depuis des mois la quasi totalité de la
compétition se déroulera à huis clos les
participants seront soumis à des
restrictions drastiques
les cas de contamination inévitable
selon ce responsable du cio du bios et à
poster mon même avec toutes les mesures
prises il y aura des cas positifs dans
le cadre de la situation du corona virus
qui englobe le monde entier il est donc
inévitable qu'il y ait des cas ce qui
est important c'est que lorsque de tels
cas surviennent nous les isole ont
correctement et systématiquement afin
qu'il n'y ait plus de transmission est
déjà critique face au maintien des géo
les japonais redoublent aujourd'hui
d'inquiétude écoutez je pensais que le
village olympique serait
/ je suis donc étonné que le virus ait
pu y pénétrer je pense que c'est
dangereux s'il est encore des cas
positifs en ce moment l'infection peut
se propager encore plus une fois que les
jeux débuteront
c'est inquiétant d'une certaine manière
je m'attendais à ce que cela se produise
je me demande pourquoi nous organisons
les jeux maintenant alors que nous les
avions repoussée d'un an
surtout quand des variantes plus
contagieux du virus apparaissent au
début je pensais que nous étions plus à
risque en recevant des personnes de
l'étranger qui pouvait être porteuses du
virus
maintenant j'espère seulement que
c'était d'années à se terminera bientôt
son côté de désastre et ils sont
d'ordinaire plus de deux millions de
fidèles venus du monde entier chez à
converger vers la mecque la ville la
plus sainte de l'islam
cette année pandémie oblige seuls 60
mille croyante sont autorisés à se
rendre à la grande mosquée pour le
pèlerinage il a démarré hier dans un
cadre sanitaire particulièrement
strictes farah mais qui ils étaient plus
de 2 millions à avoir fait le
déplacement en 2019
cette année seuls 60 mille croyants sont
autorisés à accomplir l'un des cinq
piliers de l'islam
en raison de la pandémie de kobe de 19
le piège ou grand pèlerinage se fait en
petit comité à la mecque
seule condition pour réaliser les
différents rites être résidents du
royaume d'arabie saoudite
avoir entre 18 et 65 ans et surtout être
vaccinés grâce à dieu nous avons obtenu
l'autorisation d'effectuer le hajj même
si on ne s'attendait pas à être acceptés
en raison du nombre limité de pèlerins a
accepté et comme vous pouvez le
constater le gouvernement saoudien fait
de son mieux
tout est bien organisé cette année les
autorités saoudiennes n'ont pas lésiné
sur les mesures sanitaires de nombreux
agents d'entretien ont été déployés dans
les différents lieux saints près de 1500
litres de produits désinfectants sont
utilisées quotidiennement pour nettoyer
le sol
autre nouveauté des robots sont utilisés
pour vaporiser du désinfectant
je travaille ici à la grande mosquée
depuis 15 ans aujourd'hui nous nettoyons
ce site avec trois équipes de nettoyage
qui effectue une rotation
nous nettoyons le sol dix fois avec des
désinfectants à cause du gros navires us
depuis le début de la pandémie
l'arabie saoudite a répertorié plus de
quatre cent soixante deux mille cas de
corona virus et 8000 décès le royaume
wahhabite a alors fermé ses frontières
et suspendu les entrées de pèlerins sur
son sol une industrie qui est la
deuxième source de revenus du pays après
le pétrole lui rapportant de 10 à 15
milliards d'euros chaque année
l'algérie rappelle son ambassadeur à
rabat elle reproche à la représentation
diplomatique marocaine a new yord avoir
affiché publiquement son soutien au
droit à l'autodétermination la kabylie
en tout on retrouve tout de suite notre
correspondant bassem chez bis bonsoir
bassem la décision de rapatrier son
ambassadeur prend effet immédiatement et
d'autres mesures ne sont pas exclues
selon alger bonsoir ce fut effectivement
c'est une décision assez graves et
importantes d'un point de vue
diplomatique entre les deux pays voisins
et à la fois rivaux l'essai l'est
d'alger de rapatrier son ambassadeur qui
est située à rabat avec un effet
immédiat suite à cet événement la
semaine dernière c'était trop nations
unies où la représentation maroc n va
sont ignorés distribué un tract aux pays
membres de des pays non alignés dans ce
tract qu'on pouvait lire le soutien du
royaume de marque du maroc au peuple
kabyle à l'auto la détermination un coup
de plus aux relations entre le maroc et
l'algérie à l'algérie qui a très mal
pris à cet acte le ministre des affaires
étrangères algérien lui parler d'une
trahison à jerry condamne cet acte de
manière ferme alger par nem d'une dérive
dangereuse et deux pays sont même au
bord de la rupture diplomatique de rien
on sait très bien que ces deux pays
voisins et à la fois rivaux sont en
tension depuis des années des années
sous fond du problème du sahara
occidental le ministre des affaires
étrangère algérienne a même parlé d'un
complot dirigé contre l'unité algerien
c'était la détention qui sont palpables
entre ces deux pays une gravité de la
situation qui s'est passé de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique et aux états unis
alger a promis que des mesures strictes
à l'être prendre ils attendent que le
royaume du maroc se prononcer clarifie
la situation concernant ses positions en
attendant son ambassadeur et rapatrié à
alger a agi a déclaré que d'autres
mesures pourraient être prises si le
maroc ne clarifie pas la situation
n'importe pas d'excusés ce qui s'est
passé à new york par sa délégation
merci beaucoup pour ces imprécisions ben
ça ma chemise
des dégâts surréaliste effrayant les
mots de la merkel venue constater
aujourd'hui les dommages en rhénanie
palatinat région allemande la plus
touchée par les inondations qui ont
frappé l'ouest du pays plus largement
l'ouest de l'europe la belgique le
luxembourg mais également les pays bas
ou encore la suisse ont été pris lui
aussi dans ces intempéries
florian lambert des paysages dévastés
des habitants impuissants face aux
dégâts les innovations du siècle en
europe de l'ouest ont fait au moins 183
morts en allemagne en belgique et le
bilan s'alourdit chaque jour à schuld
dans le sud ouest de l'allemagne
anga la marque elle est au chevet de la
population d'une zone sinistrée
dans une région où 110 personnes ont
trouvé la mort le visage grave mais
plein d'empathie angela merkel prend la
mesure d'une catastrophe nationale
elle qui était encore à washington quand
les intempéries ont eu lieu phénomène
qu'elle décrit aujourd'hui comme une
situation surréaliste
c'est effrayant et je dirais presque
qu'on a du mal à trouver dans la langue
allemande les mots pour décrire la
dévastation qui a été causé
cependant je dois aussi dire qu'il est
impressionnant de voir à quel point les
gens restent unis
comment ils s'entraident la solidarité
qui naît de tout cela rue d'arrêter
états lors de cette allocution est comme
le président allemand la chancelière
appelle à accélérer la lutte contre le
changement climatique
le cliché base heureusement
l'allemagne est un pays qui peut
financer la reconstruction l'allemagne
est un pays fort et nous allons
combattre cette violence de la nature à
court terme mais aussi sur le moyen et
le long terme avec une politique qui
prendra plus en compte la nature et le
climat que ce qui a été fait ces
dernières années
cela va aussi être nécessaire dans notre
famille senn
plusieurs centaines de pompiers sont
déployés dans l'ensemble du pays mais
aucun n'a jamais vécu de telles
intempéries
nous sommes très occupés
nous avons beaucoup de travail à faire
ce qui est nouveau pour nous parce que
nous n'avons jamais dû gérer une telle
situation à long terme nous devrons nous
pencher sur l'hygiène les affaires
médicales et la reconstruction de
l'infrastructure à partir de la base le
vice-chancelier et ministre fédéral des
finances
olaf scholz a promis dès la semaine
prochaine une aide d'urgence d'au moins
300 millions d'euros
en attendant un vaste programme de
reconstruction de plusieurs milliards
d'euros du nord au sud de l'allemagne et
les inondations menacent désormais à
l'autriche plus précisément la frontière
avec l'allemagne
allen petite ville située près de
salzbourg des pluies diluviennes se sont
abattues hier soir la situation est
critique selon les autorités et ont
conseillé aux riverains de ne pas se
rendre dans leur sous sol
aucune victime n'a été signalée pour le
moment alors comment expliquer ces
intempéries d'une rare violence en
europe
éléments de réponse avec arroseurs
climatologues docteur en sciences
géographiques de l'université de liège
on n'est pas dans la bonne saison on est
dans quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
observé auparavant mais qui est quelque
chose qui
est prévue par les différents scénarios
des climatologues dont je fais partie ça
fait 30 ans qu'avec le gic donc le
groupe intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat nous dit
crittenton de crier haut et fort que
cela va arriver et en fait maintenant on
y est
mais c'est quelque chose totalement
prévisibles malheureusement la majeure
partie de ces de ces dégâts matériels et
économique repose en fait sur les
individus ou sur les collectivités
locales que nationales et donc ça a un
coût phénoménal pour en fait le lien
social
on en est là et ce n'est pas seulement
une vision de l'esprit qu'on peut avoir
dans des pays du sud
extrêmement pauvre et c'est dans un an
nous sommes en europe et en europe
ceci va contribuer en fait à accentuer
les disparités sociales et c'est là
également un des drames
elle est allée bon poursuivre leur
offensive mais leur chef promeut en un
corps politique en afghanistan
il se dit résolument favorables à un
règlement politique
pourtant les combats font rage entre les
insurgés et les forces afghanes les
insurgés qui depuis le mois de mai on
garde regagné du terrain à la faveur du
retrait des troupes étrangères
les civils pente de fuir quand les
ambassades elles rapatrient leurs
ressortissants les autorités argoviennes
de rappeler elles mêmes leurs
ambassadeurs à islamabad
tant que pèse des menaces sur sa
sécurité florian lambert fuir pour
éviter la guerre
c'est le cas de milliers de civils
afghans qui ont quitté leur province au
fil des rumeurs d'attaqué imminente des
talibans aujourd'hui les insurgés
affirment contrôler 100% du territoire
et c'est désormais la capitale kaboul
qui est menacée dans différents camps de
la région avec des tentes pour seul abri
ces femmes et ces hommes n'ont plus de
quoi subvenir à leurs besoins
nous avons quitté notre village je n'ai
rien à manger et je n'ai même pas un peu
d'eau je n'ai plus rien à vendre non
plus afin de pouvoir m'acheter et quoi
que ce soit regardez il ne me reste que
la terre et le ciel
je n'ai personne à qui demander du
soutien j'ai été obligé de fuir et je
suis arrivé ici je vis maintenant sous
cette tente et je souffre beaucoup ont
souffrons tous ici car nous n'avons pas
de nourriture et nous ne recevons pas
encore d'être du gouvernement nous
venons de nous installer sous ces tentes
et nous avons beaucoup de problèmes
autre conséquence de ce conflit
certaines femmes de la ville de
jalalabad se sont sentis forcés de
quitter leur emploi anticipant le
possible retour des talibans mon métier
me plaisait mais la situation
sécuritaire s'est aggravée et les
talibans vont peut-être revenir si la
violence augmente comme en ce moment que
les combats se poursuivent dans la
plupart des districts y compris dans les
villes les femmes ne pourront plus vivre
libre dans ce genre de situation
parce que les femmes n'auront plus le
droit de travailler d'étudier ainsi de
suite
selon les autorités afghanes ce sont
plus de 3000 personnes qui auraient été
déplacées à la suite des offensives des
talibans
les ong et les institutions des
d'humanitaire maintiennent pour le
moment leur présence sur place
mais certaines s'inquiètent déjà de
l'aggravation de cette guerre civile et
dans ce contexte comment accueillir les
propos du chef du taliban des talibans
qui se dit favorable à la négociation
décryptage de david un rigoler rosso
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégie qui voit la déclaration la
délégation qui peuplent le fait que la
priorité des talibans seraient
aujourd'hui nous reste sous le par le
dialogue
alors évidemment ce type de déclarations
suscitent beaucoup de perplexité
il ya une stratégie elle est à double
détente de la palette éléments c'est à
la fois cherché à imposer un règlement
pacifique à leur profit entre guillemets
et puis maintenant la pression des armes
donc c'est une grande confusion qui
reste sur le terrain mais effectivement
la pression talibans est très fort et
ils veulent profiter également de tous
les espaces qui leur sont offertes à
perdre si terre pour ficher crédibilité
politique surtout à l'international par
maintenant au nigeria pays le plus
peuplé d'afrique où les enlèvements par
des groupes armés criminels se
multiplient dernière attaque en date il
y a deux semaines plus de 140 élèves
kidnappés dans un pensionnat du nord
ouest du pays
une vingtaine d'adolescents ont réussi à
s'échapper les familles des autres
élèves sont elles partagées entre
chagrin et colère et mini google
dévastée ses parents attendent le retour
de leur enfant
depuis deux semaines ils se réunissent
tous les jours dans la cour de leur
lycée il organise des veillées et plus
durant de longues heures
certaines mères font en sanglots
d'autres ne cachent pas leur colère
cette femme demande ou forces de
sécurité de se rendre dans la mousse
pour amener leurs enfants
l'enlèvement a lieu dans la nuit du 4 au
5 juillet à chikhoune dans l'état de
kaduna
des hommes lourdement armés pénètrent
alors dans l'enceinte de l'école à
travers entrons dans ce mur alors que
les lycéens dorment dans les dortoirs
ils sont emmenés de force dans les
forêts avoisinantes
certains n'ont même pas le temps de
prendre leurs chaussures parmi les plus
de 140 lycéens enlevé 25 ont réussi à
s'échapper
ce n'est pas le cas de judith 14 ans sa
mère s'inquiète des conditions dans
lesquelles elle est détenue par ses
ravisseurs en slovénie 3 winning la nuit
dernière je n'ai même pas pu dormir
quand il pleuvait j'imagine la pluie qui
tombe sur sa tête elle est frileuse
j'imagine comment elle peut se sentir à
cet instant regardez moi j'ai froid
alors que j'ai une couverture pour me
protéger
pensez vous que ma fille en a une voix
dit même inquiétude pour le père d'une
des jeunes filles kidnappées la nuit de
l'enlèvement
il a été prévenu par téléphone à une
heure du matin
j'ai d'abord cru à une mauvaise blague
jusqu'à ce que en arrivant dans
l'enceinte de l'école
je découvre que les enfants avaient
réellement été kidnappé je suis très
inquiet au point que parfois les mots me
manquent pour m'exprimer
[Musique]
une centaine de lycées en reste entre
les mains de leurs ravisseurs
ces derniers exigent le paiement d'une
rançon mais les parents n'ont pas les
moyens de s'y plier
craignant de voir les kidnappings se
multipliaient le gouverneur de l'état de
kaduna refuse de céder au chantage mais
les enlèvements d'élèves sont déjà
fréquents au nigeria
depuis le mois de décembre environ 1000
jeunes en ont été victimes
en 2014 les terroristes de boko haram
avait enlevé deux cents lits cnh ebook
dans le nord-est du pays
un rapt de masse qui avait soulevé
l'indignation à travers le monde
le procès pour corruption de l'ex
président sud africain jacob zuma
reprend demain son incarcération a
déclenché des scènes de pillage d'une
rare violence plus de 200 personnes ont
été tuées
le calme semble aujourd'hui être revenu
un calme précaire
retour sur une semaine de vives tensions
avec quentin au clair des vitrines
ravagé des centres commerciaux pillés de
fond en comble bilan d'une semaine
meurtrière en afrique du sud dans la
région du kwazulu natal ainsi que dans
celle de johannesburg
violences et pillages ne cessent de se
multiplier
ce vendredi le président cyril ramaphosa
s'est rendu à d'urban pour y constater
les dégâts
le chef d'état sud-africain évoque une
tentative d'insurrection mises en échec
il est clair maintenant que les
événements de la semaine dernière
n'était rien moins qu'une attaque
délibérée coordonnées et bien planifiée
contre notre démocratie l'ordre
constitutionnel de notre pays est menacé
malgré l'ampleur des dégâts cette
tentative d'insurrection a échoué elle
n'a pas réussi à obtenir de soutien
populaire parmi notre population
raison de cet embrasement
l'incarcération de l'ex président jacob
zuma âgé de 79 ans condamné à 15 mois de
prison pour outrage à la justice
il reste néanmoins populaire auprès
d'une partie de la population la colère
provoquée par l'application de cette
décision de justice a pris de l'ampleur
cette semaine
des dizaines de commerces ont été pris
d'assaut par des pillards dépassé par la
situation
les forces de sécurité ont été suppléé
par des milices armées pour assurer la
sécurité des centres commerciaux
[Musique]
ce n'est vraiment pas notre centre
commercial a été pillé il a été brûlé
totalement en ce moment nous protégeons
ce complexe ici sept enseignes
d'alimentation c'est white et nous
protégeons notre peau et c'est le seul
endroit où l'on peut se procurer de la
nourriture actuelle les nombreux actes
de pillage dont ces deux régions font
redouter des pénuries dans les magasins
qui sont encore approvisionnées devant
certains commerces
les files d'attentes peuvent s'étaler
sur des dizaines de mètres ce samedi à
durban le grand port du kwazulu natal
les sud-africains s'inquiétait de ne pas
pouvoir faire leurs courses à temps je
suis ici comme vous voyez en train de
faire des courses à cause de la pénurie
dans les magasins il n'y a pas de risque
le stock est épuisé
je ne sais pas ce que mon enfant et moi
aller manger et là vous pouvez voir je
ne sais pas combien de temps cela va me
durée de nuités nous convenons des cours
nous avons juste essayé de voir ce que
nous pouvions tenir par rapport à ce
dont nous avons besoin à la maison se
donnant donnant juste pour remplir nos
placards et rester vivant après une
semaine rythmée par l'insécurité et le
chaos
le calme regagne peu à peu le pays la
police et l'armée appuyée par des
milices populaires effectué de
nombreuses opérations pour récupérer des
biens volés lors des pillages des
fauteurs de troubles sont traqués et
arrêté mais au compte gouttes
de leur côté les habitants de
johannesburg où d'urban sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour nettoyer les rues de leur
quartier et c'est la fin de cette
édition prochain journal là à 21h à tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a donc eu cinq ans
pour se préparer cinq ans de psychodrame
50 négociations politiques
est-ce qu'elle était prêt que je 31
décembre pour redevenir une île réponse
par du moment où le royaume uni avait
décidé de quitter l'union européenne il
ne pouvait plus continuer de bénéficier
de ses droits équivalents à si vous êtes
dans l'europe pas dans l'europe
vis-à-vis des 27 est à autre ses juges